TO PALESTINIAN OFFICIALS, SO FAR
139 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED AND
AT LEAST 100 INJURED.
MEANWHILE, THE ROCKET FIRE FROM
GAZA CONTINUES.
THE ISRAELI MILITARY SAYS AT
LEAST EIGHT CIVILIANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED IN THE LAST WEEK.
RICK ROBERTSON JOINING US NOW
ISRAEL.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT THIS
LATEST STRIKE?
>> Reporter: WELL, LITERALLY AS
YOU WERE SPEAKING TO ME THERE,
I'M WATCHING DRONE INTERCEPTS
JUST BEHIND THE CAMERA IN THE
SKY.
THEY JUST INTERCEPTED ANOTHER
TWO ROCKETS.
THEY INTERCEPTED SIX BEFORE.
HAMAS SAID THEY WOULD FIRE
ROCKETS AT TEL AVIV TONIGHT.
THAT'S WHERE THEY SAID THE
RETALIATION SHOULD BE.
I'M LISTENING TO THE THUMPS OF
THOSE IRON DOME INTERCEPTS.
THE ISRAELI DEFENSE FORCES SAY
THEY TARGETED THAT BUILDING
BECAUSE THERE ARE MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS THERE BELONGING TO
HAMS'S MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
THAT WERE IN THE BUILDING.
WHAT "ASSOCIATED PRESS" ARE
SAYING, WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
RIGHT NOW IS JUST TAKING COVER.
THE SIRENS ARE GOING OFF RIGHT
NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE COVER BEHIND
A BERM.
WHEN WE CAN HEAR THE SIRENS -- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR THEM,
THAT MEANS THERE'S AN ATTACK,
ROCKETS POSSIBLY COMING IN THIS
DIRECTION.
BUT AS WE GET SOME COVER HERE,
I'M GOING TO READ TO YOU THE
"ASSOCIATED PRESS" REPORT.
YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE SOME SHELTER
AND COVER WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT THE "ASSOCIATED PRESS" SAY
ABOUT THAT STRIKE IS THIS, ON
THE BUILDING, THEY SAY WE ARE
SHOCKED AND HORRIFIED THAT THE
ISRAELI MILITARY WOULD TARGET
AND DESTROY THE BUILDING HOUSING
AP'S BUREAU AND OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS IN GAZA.
THEY HAVE LONG KNOWN THE
LOCATION OF OUR BUREAU AND KNEW
JOURNALISTS WERE THERE.
WE RECEIVED A WARNING THAT THE
BUILDING WOULD BE HIT.
WE ARE SEEKING INFORMATION FROM
THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT AND ARE
ENGAGED WITH THE U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT TO TRY TO LEARN MORE.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY DISTURBING
DEVELOPMENT, THE STATEMENT GOES
ON.
WE NARROWLY AVOIDED A TERRIBLE
LOSS OF LIFE.
A DOZEN JOURNALISTS AND
FREELANCERS WERE INSIDE THE
BUILDING AND THANKFULLY, WE WERE
ABLE TO EVACUATE THEM IN TIME.
IT CONCLUDES SAYING THIS, AND
I'M LOOKING UP THERE AND I CAN
SEE MORE INTERCEPTS, MORE
ROCKETS BEING FIRED, MORE
INTERCEPTS HAPPENING.
AND THE LAST LINE, I THINK, IS
PERHAPS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
FROM THE "ASSOCIATED PRESS" THAT
SAYS THE WORLD WILL KNOW LESS
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN GAZA
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
AL JAZEERA HAS ALSO RELEASED A
STATEMENT.
HAMAS HAVE SAID THAT THEY WOULD
RESPOND BY FIRING ROCKETS
TOWARDS TEL AVIV.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHERE THE ROCKETS
ARE GOING RIGHT NOW, BUT WHILE
WE'VE BEEN STANDING HERE, I'M
COUNTING FROM THE PUFFS IN THE
SKY FOUR INTERCEPTS.
YOU CAN SEE THERE WAS AT LEAST
HALF A DOZEN PREVIOUSLY BEFORE
IN ANOTHER DIRECTION.
SO IT SEEMS THAT WITH ONE
INCIDENT, AS WE'VE SEEN SO MANY
TIMES, ONE INCIDENT BEGETS
ANOTHER ROUND OF INCIDENTS.
EARLIER TODAY ROCKETS FIRED FROM
GAZA DID GET THROUGH, A COUPLE
OF THEM GOT THROUGH THE IRON
DOME DEFENSIVE SHIELD.
THEY LANDED AROUND TEL AVIV
WHERE SIRENS ARE GONE OFF.
ONE MISSILE LANDED ON A STREET
NEAR SHOPS AND A 50-YEAR-OLD MAN
WAS KILLED IN THAT.
SO THIS EVENING, HEADING INTO
THIS EVENING HERE, REAL CONCERN,
INTERNATIONAL CONCERN ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THAT BUILDING
HOUSING JOURNALISTS.
WE KNOW THAT JAN PSAKI AT THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS SAID THAT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH THE ISRAELI
GOVERNME